[Music]
[Applause]
that's cool
chris mannix he's a senior writer
covering the nba for sports illustrated
joining us on the program
nba shut down a year ago on this day
what do you remember about that
i remember being relieved for a minute
because i had been scheduled to do
back-to-back celtics games for local tv
there i just finished writing a story i
was exhausted
i remember thinking like great you know
this will be like a week
a couple of days off i can get back into
the flow after kind of a mini vacation
didn't turn out that way yeah when it
first happened
and i remember paulie text me said turn
on espn and i turned on espn
and it wasn't like 11 o'clock at night
to watch sportscenter
it was eight o'clock and you're going
wait a minute what's going on on espn
oh they got a basketball game no they're
supposed to have a basketball game and
then all of a sudden it was basically uh
oklahoma city drive home safely and then
you realized
okay what's this mean and who would have
thought
you know that sacramento later on they
had to tell that you know it's like
hey there's contact tracing with these
officials and
i mean it's pretty incredible what
happened what what happened quickly with
the nba
and then everybody else sort of followed
suit yeah yeah it was
when you look back on it now it it was
remarkable i remember
i think it was the hawks game that
turned out to be vince carter's last
game of his career there
and i remember kind of wondering like
you know
what are you guys doing why even
finishing this game i mean like you know
the whole referee thing you were talking
about you just wondered why everybody
didn't just stop
short right there and end it but i i
think that goes to show that
back then nobody believed that this was
going to have the kind of impact
on the season that it had i remember
talking to coaches executives
uh in the the days that followed all of
them had said look it's probably going
to be about a week
for this thing to settle down then we'll
come back in empty arenas there was an
acceptance
that they'd be back in limited to no
capacity at arenas but
no no comprehension that
this could wind up shutting the league
down until they can go into a bubble
and remember lebron said that he's not
playing if there's no fans in the stands
and that was i was in la for that and
somebody asked that he he was kind of
walked into that
a little bit where yeah he was he didn't
know
about all the things that were going on
in that moment when
the nba said that he's you know of
course he responds you know i'm not
playing without fans i play for the fans
well
that obviously changed uh very quickly
as
as the reality of the situation kind of
set in
you know you look back on the bubble and
we didn't know it was going to work
and you know you had some players who
were adversely affected by it
but i still maintain what lebron and the
lakers pulled off
is as memorable and as difficult as any
team
has gone through with no home court
advantage there a sterile environment
have we given the lakers enough credit
for what they pulled off
in winning that championship i think we
have
um i'm i'm kind of a tough person
to talk to about the challenges of the
bubble dan because
sitting in a hotel room eating buffalo
wings is not all that abnormal from my
day-to-day life so it's
it really is like i kind of say that i
mean i i i
sympathize with people that have
families and are away from them that's
just not me and so if you like tell me
that
i can get wings 24 hours a day like i'm
and
there's a never-ending supply of candy
in the mess hall like i don't
i don't really do all that but you could
see it i mean
when you're in that bubble and i was in
it for two plus months
you can see the the mental wear and tear
it takes on players in real time from
from the first week where everybody's
kind of like all right we can do this we
can hang by the pool no big deal
till like the second month when you see
these guys walking to the dining hall
just trudging heads down not a lot of
conversation
amongst each other sitting down getting
through a meal
and then going back to their room it
obviously had an enormous mental toll
uh taken on these guys so i don't know
where you rank it among the most
difficult things the nba team has done
to win a championship but it it's up
there to be able to go
three plus months and and win a title
chris mannix the sports illustrated
senior nba writer joining us i saw
an article a column and it had to do
with
espn speaking to some several uh
prominent figures around the nba and
that there
was a radical proposal that maybe you
could limit the number of threes you
attempt
in a game let's say it was first half
you got to attempt
20. uh second half 20
and then after that everything counts as
two until the final six minutes
of the game are are we getting to the
point is it too much of a good thing
[Music]
that what the three-pointer means to the
nba right now
we're not getting to that point um
you can't put the genie back in the
bottle and this is what the nba wanted
uh 20 plus years ago when the ratings
were starting to dip
the physicality of the game was causing
too many low scoring games you remember
that time dan you know david stern and
nba brass i mean they wanted what we're
seeing right now a free-flowing game
a lot of three-point shots maybe they
didn't want it at the level that we're
seeing where teams are just
reflexively shooting 35 43 points per
game sometimes
more but this is the trade-off this is
what you get the idea that they're going
to
limit three-pointers in a game is just
it's as likely as them
ultimately instituting the four point
shot which was kind of a running joke
you know 10 or 15 years ago this you're
you're gonna have to deal with the
fallout because
this has helped grow the game think
about the most popular players
in the game the most emulated players in
the game it begins with steph curry and
it goes down to all these three-point
shooters
that have helped make the game as
popular as it is today
it just it just is what it is dan you're
not going to be able to change
what the nba has become but is there a
really good team who doesn't rely on the
three-pointer as much as everybody else
does
i mean there are teams that do it on a
super sized level
um i don't have the numbers in front of
me on which team ranks towards the
bottom
but every team is gonna jack them up at
a high level especially in the fourth
quarter i mean look dan
coaches in the nba every coach this is
what they
they teach the best shots are layups
dunks and three-pointers
the way that michael jordan and kobe
bryant played the game
every coach would try to dissuade them
of that nowadays they don't want
mid-range jumpers they don't want turn
around post shots because they have been
deemed
inefficient layups free throws threes
that is
all every coach wants from their team
you know you might see some numbers dip
here and there from one team to another
but
by and large that's the philosophy well
i got utah is the number one three-point
shooting team
in in the nba the sixers are the lowest
the lakers are in the bottom five as
well now i don't know if that changes
when we get to the postseason or later
in the season
but you know do you have to be
jacking them up and are you all in on
utah being a a team to beat or
you know one of the teams to beat i
don't think you have to be jacking them
up
to be a championship team especially
when you're talking about the lakers and
sixers who are both
uh you know at least can be elite
defensive teams with the the personnel
that they have so if you can be great on
that end uh you're fine
i am buying the jazz as a serious threat
to win a championship because
i was going through this over the
all-star break there's really nothing
the jazz do that you look at and say
that's not sustainable
you've got mitchell playing at a high
level which is a natural progression
of his game mike conley was not great
last year but this is the mike conley
dan that we've seen
for most of his career the guy that we
saw playing so well
in memphis goldberg to me is a sneaky
mvp
candidate i mean he has become such a
presence offensively with his screen
setting
that he's a real impact player on that
end of the floor without shooting the
three they've been
an elite defensive team during quinn
snyder's time there certainly
when you get into the playoffs i want to
see if mitchell can make plays
if conley can make plays end of game
situations
but right now like the only question you
have is can like jordan clarkson
continue to be
the sixth man of the year type of player
or does he revert to being an
inconsistent gunner other than that
i'm pretty sold on what the jazz are
yeah but i can't give rudy gobert
mvp credit if he sets nice screens chris
of course you can no i can't why
can you imagine that where you're going
uh what did he do so well
man can he okay okay now you're now
you're twisting words here like it's not
it's not he's just this great screen
setter he's also the most intimidating
defensive presence the league has seen
since mutumbo
so like that's a big factor in all this
but offensively you ask those jazz
players and i've done this
like you know what's what's go bear's
influence and he just sets
some bone crushing screams that frees up
these guys is an impact
okay like he's already never gonna be a
three-point shooter dan that's obvious
but if he can be a massive screen setter
that'll impact the offense
the lakers can't win a title without a.d
can the nets win a title without kd
no neither i don't think the lakers
frankly can win a title without dennis
schroeder for that matter but that's a
conversation for
for another time and he's been that
impactful for them
um look the nets are going to
test the theory if that that you
need to be a top tennis defensive team
to win a championship they're not going
to be that type of team no matter how
many guys
they sign off the street in the next
couple of weeks
uh but because they're so dynamic
offensively at full strength because
they've got three guys
which is almost unprecedented three guys
that can take over a game in the fourth
quarter they can get away with being a
middle of the pack or worse
defensive team but without durant
without him being completely healthy
there's too many good teams in the
eastern conference i think that can
knock them off
great to talk to you again chris i hope
you're well i i thought you'd appreciate
screen setting like you know kind of a
grinder in your day
i i know but i just i mean it's it's
nice i mean i didn't
set screens i was a shooter so right but
you went around them right so you
knew the value of a screen yeah but
you know you know it wasn't you know one
of those things where i said
gosh you know that guy he's more
valuable than i am
it didn't matter if they were setting
screens or not for me i mean okay
okay next time you have reggie miller on
ask him that question
he didn't need screens he just ran all
day
well you don't just run without getting
a screen set for you that's crazy the
reason
you're running is you're kind of trying
to rub guys off screens and reggie had
by the way
two of the better ones in the davis
twins antonio and dale who just
set rocking stuff they weren't twins
i know it's they were called that though
like that's i know there weren't twins
i i just think you hate the french
i i i don't i don't hate the french
i i love tony parker just him
yes yes rudy and the go bearers
i love i love rudy god i'm going to tune
in to the next jazz game just to watch
him set screens
god it's god i'm telling you must see tv
i know i know thank you chris
you got it chris maddox
sports illustrated senior basketball
writer and a man who loves a
good screen